the center of the board so g2 g3 might
be induced but 94 knight of three to e5
has to be considered g2 g3 normal move
let's just put another move on the board
94 and then I really like this idea of
Knight f4 posting up bringing more
pieces more and more pieces over here to
the kingside ideas of Knight takes d5
and capturing this night on c4 pop up in
the position for white more intuitive so
I think that I go for that line yeah so
I mean easier to find the 95 with a
little bit more unusual you have to like
look for some tactics right so again
after this position Bishop c7 the
Queen's have been traded in the kenski
version of Cobie in game alright let's
see it's not a thrilling game going on
in the first tight break game he's white
it looks like now he's like kind of
plain black right yeah he sees the
defensive and it looks like he's hanging
on this looks like it's going to be a
draw this game exactly and white to play
white is likely to just bring his King
over to d1 and then just start trading
lots of pieces on the C file and the
tension mounts in the US Chess
Championship as this game is a draw
Kamsky playing white what do you think
he would play with the white pieces this
silly London system yeah what what he
was successful with with Josh wheedle he
just likes slow steady games and he's
really really good and jumping on his
opponent on a very very simple slip is
all for you never know
you think that's quite unlikely and
rapid I mean he hasn't won a very nice
game against Reggina Cobian in the
French before yes indeed he does god it
does light playing against both the
French as well as the caro-kann
two favorite defenses by var so you're
right efore is a very reasonable choice
and you'll be excited for game and
probably 100% lady for her sure I think
that you guys jumping the gun a little
bit here look at the clock situation
guys it's 647 to 1109 Chomsky's the one
with a time advantage I think he's
playing for a win in this position this
is no risk at all he's equalized it's
clear for him that there's no problems
whatsoever black is trying to win
version is the one who's gonna have to
make a draw here and he's down to five
minutes on the clock
he's gonna have to make some precise
moves to save himself well okay it's
still a draw let me not overstate that
but he is definitely not stopping here I
think Tomsky thinks if I can win this
game with the advantage that I have the
match is over the match is over so he
will press firuzan here
stronger player with extra time on the
clock you've got to like what black is
doing in this game and it looks as
though he's trying to prove himself in
this position despite the near equality
Tomsky has been known to win positions
like this before so let's see if he can
put some pressure on his opponent in the
other game Tata of Abraham yan is
definitely trying to prove herself as
well but it looks as though this bishop
on d4 is a very solid defensive piece
and it's not so easy to get the attack
going in the game so we'll see what
happens in that game guys yeah indeed it
looks like tocqueville hi indeed play
Queen age takes after we're going after
you Juan so instead of your 93 move
Irina just played rook e1 and now after
Queenie she has played g3 right
increases her attack yet well I really
didn't like this move rook rook F 1 e 1
is all no because you're just always
allowing these types of sacrifices you
know yeah good point you're actually
kind of allowing even the possibility
right now exactly not sufficient right
now because you can maybe you can just
play King well Bishop takes allows Queen
takes H 2 followed by Queen takes g3
which doesn't really look
much fun right you could also play
Bishop takes g3 check and snap off this
rook on e 1 so instead maybe taking with
the king and then seeing after h2
whether we could just defend this more
bravely you're trying to come in for
Queen takes g3 but what if I just play
work Jiwon do you have an effective over
here well I don't see because I it looks
like I'm covering all the key squares
yeah and I'm just saying that these
types of attack are no fun to calculated
I'm betting she does it that's my baby
well I think she's sacking on f2 she
actually hasn't she's started with rook
to e6 she played you can see did you see
that smirk that sly smile on her face
she's looking to capture on f2 it's in
her head and she's now just bringing the
rook up to do the little bit extra as
she turns in the screws arena better
watch out because she's up against a
dangerous tactician and I think Abraham
Iran has played masterfully down upon
and just saying whatever let's play CC
just glanced at the clock she's saying
let's just keep this game going don't
trade anything off let her consolidate
I'm going for the win I'm impressed by
how she's handled herself I like it I
mean I honestly think that she just sees
the game 25 is ultimately gonna end in a
five-minute game I don't think she sees
his massive difference between game 25
and 5 sounds oversimplified but I think
she's thinking that eventually it's
gonna be a five-minute game anyway so
why not cease activity right that is
reason for earlier right but this attack
by black looks I mean okay sometimes the
crude caveman attack finds its mark but
it does strike me as a little bit right
just quickly responded with Bishop h3
obviously she's not excited about
trading but now maybe Irina is a rookie
one will will shed some light on it and
she'll be able to play Bishop to f1
right bishop I say insist on trades
rather I I wouldn't do that myself I'm
sitting there saying to myself I like
your Bishop on h3
why do I like your bishop on i-93
because your queen is not going to go to
h3 so maybe now's the time to - okay
very very dangerous would be to play the
move Queen a for that might allow black
too much of a free hand on the King side
I'm thinking that she should just play
the move Knight d3 with the idea of
playing Knight f4 trying to force trades
or at least to induce you metallic to
play the move g7 g 5 and after Knight G
to black still has a lot to prove here
well yeah absolutely just like
constantly calculating it you know right
even in a position where we have to give
up a lot of our good pieces like we can
look at it I didn't know she but you had
played Bishop that long
oh say so Queen h4 G for this move she's
a little bit behind on the clock so
she's trying to catch up 7 minutes for
Irina a little over 5 4 talk ff13
captures the rook rather than leave the
quantity to a little Lucie and she has
captured and it's gotta be g5 there's
just no other choice for black its force
majeure as they say so her idea remember
I said I don't like the to allow that
Queen to come to h3
so I like black having the bishop on h3
so g5 and in case of Knight f3 Knight g2
is the alternative night of 5 we're
going to see Queen h3 and the rook
coming over and that's Gary that is very
scary no I don't think arena is going to
be happy about that night h4 in some
positions but worked a cage for pawn
takes h4 and remember there's also a
bishop on ba yeah guys remember her
Queen's on c2 so she can guard the h2
square with some kind of push so this
has to be done she can always put her
knight on
d six in this position okay she could
even play f3 actually because her queen
is ready to come over and defend the
position and she has played nine so this
this had to be done she has to include
her Queen in the defense and look to
play this move f3 or maybe 9 to d6
returning the pawn at some point but you
got to admit Tata has shown that she can
get some counter play and guess what
this one is gonna go down to the wire
and she has played this movement Wow
they followed the line f3 instantly by
crush so we've guessed the player's
moves and now what arena's saying is
please take my knight if you take my
knight I'll recapture and if we have a
Queen trade well guess what at the end
of the day you're gonna have regrets
that you played the move g5 because has
retreated and played Queen takes e4 Wow
and now I move has recaptured the Queen
yet we have to end games so we just have
to play Queen takes Queen she could keep
the Queen's on blacks attack is gone now
maybe Queen f2 is on the board he's
potentially on the board as well so
white also black also Queen up to
threatens f7 we do have to watch out for
Knight b3 which would take a take a
beautiful Bishop off the board but Queen
f2 immediately threatening s7 and that's
exactly what Irina is thinking about now
does you want to throw in that move and
play the middle game we should note the
pawn is is no longer an advantage right
there's no point advantage for white
white return new pawn that's right so so
crush has lost or pawn advantage and the
time so very close that was going to go
down to a blitz guys we should know the
other game calm ski is up 6 minutes on
the clock
version is down to 2 minutes and change
in his game so Kamsky needs to just make
a couple of moves the position looks
dead equal but if calm ski can make some
moves
it basically version is spotting calm
ski seven and a half minutes to 253
that's not easy spot a guy like calm ski
let's give you four and a half minutes
on the clock how do you feel about that
can you beat me still even
positions you can slip up and I think
councils gonna press him for sure well
one person who agrees with Grand Master
Maurice Ashley tweeting at us at our
house join us chess chance Yann
Gustafson he's also with chess 24 and he
says he disagrees with us even though
we're doing a great job I hate to be why
I think agrees with Maurice Maurice is
our okay so basically what version said
wait a minute your only idea is to bring
your King into my position I'll play the
move rook g1 which sets me up for f2 f3
I think the positions are dead draw by
the way I don't see anything anything
anything zero zero zero chances but if
got it does something really wrong well
that may be maybe Akopian will try to
play me for it's a draw it's clearly
equal dead equal but aren't you worried
about the clock just a little bit he's
got two minutes and he's still thinking
he's still if it's so easy why is the
movie spent so for 40 seconds on this
move alone after King f5 what's going on
well I really don't know what's going on
in VARs head about that decision but I'm
just thinking that after f2 f3 keeping
blacks King at bay
I just he's making it hard on himself
continue to rise in that game so Queen
f2 on the board thought to have played
Queen g6 now she actually has an
advantage in the clock she's got five
minutes but it's really gonna it's
really gonna be extremely close remember
guys it's very different than the
regular time controlled in the old three
second increment and I think that both
players are maybe forgetting that a
little bit I'm truly surprised by arenas
position be arenas decision I beg your
pardon because I really thought that
after the Queen trade it's very clear
that White's rook it was going to come
to f5 in case of pawn takes rook comes
to f5 the other rook comes to f1 and
White's got already made initiative on
the Kings side that wasn't her decision
she played Queen
- Queen attacking the part on f7 Queen
drop back to g6 defending the pawn and
no way to plead we're going to a did you
want to prevent perhaps Knight to b3
ideas getting the knight back into the
game and trying to remove that beautiful
bishop on d4 and we have seen Knight be
393 anyway and now Irina's played to
move a 404 well really I mean I'm sorry
rook to e8 happened before
93 Tata did not play and I'd be free
immediately play Brooklyn d d8 look on D
2 e 8 ok doubling rooks now after a 4/4
okay yeah I really do 93 and Irina
played 93 right which I thought was was
needed for quite some time so this is
interesting she really now she thinks
that if Knight takes d4 this is gonna be
a positional error because a Knight is
eventually
yeah the knight is eventually gonna
prove to be the better minor piece in
the endgame possibly going to e5 later
in the game down to 119 on his clock his
time is ticking down critically in that
position should no Tomsky still has 546
lots of time on his clock a really
serious situation now for white in terms
of the clock even though it's clearly a
drawing position there is no question
comes he's trying to win this game if he
offered the draw Cobian would stick his
hand out right now
oh absolutely clearly comes he's
actually trying to win but only with
this balanced e-file how can he win I
don't know but he's played the move b5
now clearly that's his only chance he's
trying to see what he can nibble on that
side still an equal position but big
edge on the clock the gigantic edge I
don't forget 5 second or a minute not 30
do the plays realize that of course they
do mentally but do they realize it in
their bones because they've been playing
for two weeks with the 30 second exact
Tommy on a little bit ahead on irena
question the clock and she kept the
tension with working for and I think
that's why you see tactic being the only
one in the championship so far that
seems to have a realistic chance against
this powerhouse to in the championship
because she doesn't play moves like
Knight
sixty-four she keeps attacking we saw
yesterday between me amazingly prepared
in this tournament but she's any chance
he had to trade against Irina she took a
she did you know especially in
high-pressure yeah in fact you have
really fearless with her pants rack
sacrifice well that's amazing I just
don't understand why he isn't just
simply playing g4 and well he must have
going down I guess he went down to forty
something and then got his five second
increment I just don't understand why he
isn't playing g4 and trading pawns on
the kingside and just get it going in
case of be for Bishop would drop back to
t2 in case of rook h8 the bishop would
drop back to e one and come on a forty
grand party grand on the line he's
playing gotta calm ski he's never won
the title you've won it four times you
know how to handle yourself here he's
super nervous is easy as it could if you
gave him all the time in the world
he knows it's a draw but he still has to
make moves and you see that he's scared
I mean he's worried right now with all
those seconds ticking down five a three
is played by a cobia but let's please go
back to actually you really are getting
exciting there after work to e4 Irina
crash played the move c6 because that
pawn is for the moment taboo with the
pawn on f7 so the question now is this
going to be a strong passed pawn or as
positive eventually going to be able to
capture this pawn and end up turning her
sacrifice into a pawn surplus well God
takes c6 takes c6 he immediately jumped
to it with rook c8 renewing the plot the
attack on his pawn and now Irena night
before both defending the pawn on c6 and
also hitting that pawn on d5 and now
what on earth is going on well I was
about to say if that night lands on d5
and on its way to f6 it's over
I mean Knight takes d5 Knight f6 is just
simply huge that's just it so type here
must find accurate moves now she is in
big trouble
arena is unwinding remember she was
totally on the defensive that's gone she
has now taken over the initiative
and we know Tata Abraham Jana does not
want to be defending so it's going to
take her more time now to look at the
position now that her attack is dead
look at those disjointed black pieces no
attack at all
so arena crush has imposed her own
personality back on the game she's not
defending she's attacking and that's not
where Tata Bob Romney on wants to be and
psychologically I think she's in a lot
of trouble now
mmm and she is she's not whipping our
moves that's right both players with a
two minutes and six seconds on the clock
and I'll talk to dipping beneath I arena
for the first time not the first time in
the game but the first time in a little
while all right I think she started out
the game actually with a little bit last
time in the opener seconds on the clock
in the Ocoee but a much more exciting
position happening in the ladies event
I'm looking at Queenie six it's almost
box actually Queen f6 instead was arena
played I'm not Queen a5 the Queen
threatening matin one by the way just
played Knight takes d4 okay hold on
there's a swishing Zook in the position
Jen we can capture on g5 we don't have
to recapture at once on the deef I swear
you know I'm a punk rubber so I sure and
I mean it's thinking so I think you saw
it I think maybe I'd have missed this
move but and how is it but I don't know
should I take it best move grab the pawn
grab one Queen g6 that would force me to
trade Queens she has taken unhappy with
development I don't think she saw this
move did you play King f8 whoa
that's huge I think arenas in boss now
look at that
Queen tech g5 check King f8 don't like
that move one single bit oh my I think
thoughts you have way overplayed her
hand in this game lost here Wow takes
knight on d4 and what what conversation
does she have the defy
on his toast and her King is exposed
she's no longer attacking at all I think
the game is completely turned around and
a reader crush is winning on the board
however she's still got to make the
moves is it's a blitz situation now any
kind of blunder could happen but I've
seen arena crush move super fast so I
couldn't believe her hand speed watching
her play blitz so I think once she if
she reads herself she you've got a room
you've got to get your mind set right
after playing for so long
which I like by the way I like before
she is dropped down under a minute but
her position doesn't seem that difficult
the play as we see more trades coming on
the board do I do disagree with Maurice
and then I think positive is the faster
player know what I'm saying she's fast
enough she's up and winning don't think
you're gonna flag her that's fast enough
that if she's winning but if she's but
it served him speed I think Tata is
faster I totally agree with you there
but that last move rook takes before was
not the best move according to the
engines now it's not nearly as
advantageous for arena if a trade
happens on d4 and a5 clocking the piece
but she did not do that she played
rookie 300 both players fans must be
absolutely going crazy with both players
under a minute no leeway of a 30-second
increment this is kind of heart stopping
for everyone even though Irina is
winning the game she 1995 absolutely.i
with an attack against look on to play
by PES rookie - we know that when a
knight gets to f6 that's usually kaput
b7 is killing if she finds it she missed
it see someone was winning on the spot
in fish we played Oscars move Knight to
f6 check how is that not good as well
that looks great
Bishop to e5 does that move even
possible isn't there a 9700 arena's
definitely just yes for sure under
control big time here 29 seconds for
tots have 45 seconds I really just need
to find some good moves
what why doesn't night h7 check win on
the spot it does win on the spot it's
gonna be mate if she be a queen gh King
seven D seven check that's the bank if
she finds it and spending the time on
the critical work to descend
oh my oh my the position is almost equal
again six the night died she missed it
she was only 16 seconds left and the way
same thing guys the same oh wow look are
you saying a lot of moves are being
trotted out fast between arena and
tucked F oh my 21 seconds of the Koski
game by the way they're dead even in
that game from what I can tell both
sides down to that under 30 seconds I'm
gonna switch games for a second ah but
it's dead dead draw come on nothing to
discuss let's go back because the board
as well and Irina cross Tata barber ha
me in and out
Irina crush is able to get those two
rooks on the seventh capturing all the
pawns
that's a it's a draw Oh No arena really
really spoiled what was a forced winning
line with Knight takes h7 check how
could she miss like in 40 seconds with
five second increments are you joking
what what has happened after the Queen
trained the front rook the rook and then
drop the rook back to F two after King
g8 rook F ng a rook F 2 and rookie four
was played now it says white is winning
again if she just takes on 87th and she
did take on a 7-7 it allowed a Czech kg
to which which Czech rooks Iran rook e1
check okay one check behind on and now
two pawns up for white pawns up simple
winner suddenly again completely winning
in fact
has a chance to time bank you know in
this position she certainly can normally
with an incremented thought so easy and
what has happened after work a one
Maurice rip d1 d2 was playing to DD
seven double rooks on the sash is
winning again incredibly h5 rook g7
check has been played and it's all she
wrote she's gonna be three pawns up and
having a meeting attack look it's not
too taut tip is disgusted she just shook
her head there and then the last pawn is
dropped she's down three pawns she can
only pray but with that increment
there's no way she should survive this
position rook takes me drop yeah of
course whoopsy to check here let's on
the board you have to see to came to H
and now doubled rooks on the rank and
now it's up to her thinking now what to
do here well the simplest of course is
to give the King g4 King G for rook she
thought that move she played King g4
instead and a check and she repeated the
position congratulate rook g5 check yep
and repeated checks a King f8 rook f5
check King g8 and then King to g4 now
ready to block with a rook clever he's
able to block with her rook in this
moment nice looks like she decided she
doesn't want to block with her ping g5
has been played rook check King g5 yes
and rook check rooks e4 check king g5
Wow
and she said what takes h2 ok and now
arena looks like she's ready to rope in
the victory something like rookie
fiberboard rook b5 with the threat of
check matin to rook c8 defending that
check but now Rena can advance her pawn
advance her King double on the seventh
King g6 has occurred with ideas such as
rook g7 check in the position and what
is happening for work the GA check wow
what is this
rook g8 check
very wrong oh my goodness
something went very wrong rook have to
check just happened has it been played
g6 check
oh my throwing it a little finesse with
it now you can't go to the seventh ring
because there's a check a new g5 Carrick
King King d5 yes King d5 rook g5 check
King c6 looks like she's going into the
Haven of those but only eight seconds
under clocks are gonna the banks on time
again Wow no one's gonna take that pawn
on g4
well hold on there's a rubber check on
the back rank all arena needs to do is
trade a pair of rooks and shield she
will win with her past a pawn
so I don't think taught EF can capture
rook takes g4 check King b7 and now with
the King in the way she's taking on g4
this is a different ending this is
difficult for absolutely this is a very
difficult ending in fact and what she
has played moved to play q28 with her
with the same same ideas what we've seen
before to play rook b8
my goodness what king five past pounds
must be pushed work a4 rook a for a six
hasn't been played yet
Irina's on move he six drops no it
doesn't that's a nice nice move nice
move by Arena
what does that because of rook b8 Wow
yes f8 and then the work on a6 would be
hanging
she played rook F a cheap labor can a
nice art work b8 happened and out I
thought I played work to be for rook to
be for yes Roque white is winning rook
takes King takes just rook d7 a7 and
it's over
it's bad the Queen guys just grab the
Queen it knows that it's over
wow it's over so the only try here so
what has come before that you see behind
Wow
the first game of the playoffs heater at
the u.s. women's chess champion Jen Wow
my good friend
Alejandra Ramirez trying to console her
there's a big game yet to come
she's gonna have another crack and I
Reno with the white pieces and after
that anything can happen boys for sure
boy did she go for arena two in this
game even with the black pieces she was
fearless she sacrificed a part she went
g5 everything was going King site arena
defended really well and pulled it out
in a scramble but that was mad and the
second game is going to be and we will
be with you for the second game of this
rapid match in just a few minutes
stay with us so we're here at the u.s.
Chess Championships and u.s. women's
championships in st. Louis Game two of
the wrap is coming soon
[Music]
hi I'm Lindsay part of the admissions
team here at Paul Mitchell school st.
Louis our campus is located on Maryland
Plaza right here in the gorgeous Center
West End
I chose Tom Mitchell the school signa
list because I visited other schools and
when I was at them I just felt like the
energy level wasn't the same it wasn't
as elevated as that it is here when I
came here it just felt right
everybody looked great everybody had
such a great attitude the facility was
really clean and just so much more
advanced technology can truly enhance
your education when we brought in
Chromebooks and we started using the
Smart TVs we really tapped into the 21st
century learner being a student of Paul
Mitchell is great because the learning
leaders are there to guide you in the
right direction they give you the
opportunity to make decisions on your
own
they accept you for who you are and
they're always welcome and honest and
open we have encouraged our guests to
host Google reviews so far to date have
over 100 reviews with an average rating
of 4.5 stars
so I'd like that this isn't just for
hair and beauty but it's also business
college you can learn hair you can brush
that you can tease that you can learn
all of that but to do business that's
something that really takes a whole
different level of Education
whether we're in the classroom are at
the color bar we're always having a
great time at Paul Mitchell the school
st. Louis
being a student Paul Mitchell gives you
a lot of opportunity for when you're
ready to get out into the real world
thank you for taking a sneak peek of our
campus and we can't wait for you to come
and see what a Paul Mitchell education
can do for you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
be surprised be intrigued be delighted
the world chess Hall of Fame in st.
Louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love three galleries
highlight the history culture and
creativity behind the game explore chess
in ways you never imagined it's a
one-of-a-kind cultural institution where
rare artifacts and world-class art play
together the world chess Hall of Fame
mind art experience welcome to the world
of the soohyun you take the blue pawn
return to the comfortable world of chess
tournaments as you know you take the red
part I'll show you a chess event your
wildest imagination
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey welcome back to the 2014 US
Championships and u.s. women's
championship playoff we like to take a
minute to thank everyone behind the
scenes who made this championship
possible the staff at the st. Louis
chess club and the high-tech equipment
provided by spectrum studios and fat Jim
studios amazing job this production team
has done we'd also like to thank chichi
and joy Bray for the event organization
the house was started for those
beautiful tests that everyone from the
st. Louis chess club 20 Ritchie
executive director Aaron Matt Barrett
here was helping us with production Alex
Martin are in Carroll directly amazing
arbiter team and they had to go into
overtime of course so thank you to them
we'd also like to thank our web team
Mike wilmarie a great PR he's been
getting for us and our our Fleischman
our PR team as well who helped get us
into USA Today thank you
Grandmaster Yasir Sauron and Grandmaster
Maurice Ashley and Grandmaster Jennifer
Shahaji
don't forget the people of Lester's
we've got grandmasters Robert has and
Ben Feingold and they've also been doing
a commentary at the US Championships for
our live audience the world chess Hall
of Fame has helped us with a bunch of
the events including the amazing reunion
concert that was a highlight absolute
highlight and Shannon belly was
instrumental in putting that all
together along with the director of the
world chance fall of Fame Larry list the
curator and the director of the Hall of
Fame Susan Barrett has also been lending
me some clothes and Bill and of the
artists themselves who help make this
show possible
that's right Glen Keane Owen Cage and
they're coming back for Bernie more so
more kind of excitement on combining art
and Jeff wonderful wonderful wonderful
and a set up of course is that arena has
taken the lead she'll need to draw but
boy that came fast and furious at the
end that that's that's time scramble
between arena and Tatia boy I my heart
was racing and I'm not even playing in
the event so I just saw what they must
be going through right now
well I am you also do have a comment
from Grand Master Hikaru Nakamura yes he
says that it's such a shame that Harbor
ha me and didn't know the bank worried
defense from games like Botvinnik Fisher
and Roger Bobb Nakamura and I think
that's the defense with her we're coming
to the sixth rank that's right and that
kind of helps the makes it so that if
the pawn pushes forward you can bring
the work behind upon and reach that and
game after delivering a whole series of
checks when Kura was a Czech problem
composer from the 1930s who discovered
this defense and by the way hikaru
played it and what used it in one of his
games to hold that position that arena
one I wager that active does no this
defense it's been covered and don't
wretzky in quite some detail but that
she just wasn't able to execute yeah the
time situation was just yeah undermine
you that got to play moves and she found
the wrong defense that's really why you
need to know the those those types of in
games backwards and forwards because
when you get them it's not like your
city it should be instead to remember
you really have to just execute it
instantly exactly it should be instinct
and Nakamura before that game actually
said that his US Championship
predictions were Kamsky and active but
after the game I think he's probably
revising it but also he was a he was
championing the cause of var earlier in
the event before they got to the
playoffs who who could have known that
var would had this preliminary match
that he needed to win so that that was
hurtful but now var has the black pieces
we know he's a very very solid player
God is not I'm not expecting gada to
come out on the opening with big
theoretical novelty or anything like
that he just wants a solid position but
then again you have alerted me eetu e4
by Kamsky and playing against a French
defense in a karo a defense is something
he likes Maurice your thoughts I just
wanted to note that a bit of meditation
that it seems
is a ritual of calm skis before every
single round you saw him just close his
eyes breathe deeply for several seconds
before finally coming out of it I don't
show exactly why he does that at
something maybe we could ask him if he
wins the game but he seems to do it
every single time and he's now calm and
ready for battle and I think that calms
he's got a big edge right now this this
last game he proves he could equalize
with ease
he better not get black if there's an
Armageddon game because I don't think a
cobia will stand a chance breaking down
his wall so I think he knows right now
if he plays solidly he'll either win or
draw and if they goes to the Armageddon
game invar better bid low low low
because calm ski where black is going to
be the Great Wall of China you just not
gonna break that down and we've got the
women's game as well pack them up raha
me in a must-win situation so she's
gonna be hoping get another exciting
Sicilian no surprises here she has
played 1.e4 I should mention that
sometimes we get a chance to mention
hashtag us chess attempts comments
especially if you're Hikaru Nakamura on
goose Gosselin but keep them coming we
are repeating the best ones and we do
have chess comprises to get out today
thank you also to our sponsors chess
calm and to fleischman-hillard who's
been getting us some grief yaar during
the championship now what is this
opening in a regular game we're bringing
up and has got to play d4 lead you
predicted Yasir like you play d4 and
Bishop f4 the London system that he's
that that he's used to great
effectiveness she was Championships a
definite practical choice in a rapid
game you can't really blame him for that
because bars gonna have to think a lot
earlier than he would have to think if
he thought you know without 15 moves of
theory in the franchise and he wanted
guys by the way he won this game it's
gotta have good memories he just won
against Trudel in the system the london
system so you know he's got fresh good
memories in his mind of playing just
this line exactly
although bars played it quite
differently by the way after 85 we I
believe we have a d6 in our game with
that's EF Knight c3 a6 I think I've got
the right position on the board Bishop
e7 so a different twist to the special
akov with this system Bishop e7 well I
guess Y can just play the normal line
here Knight c4 and reroute her Knight
so the idea behind 94 is obviously
Bishop e3 and Knight b6 not only
dominating on the D Phi squared but also
the b6 square so I don't think b7 b5 has
been played in by arena yes 93 and
native six on the board and it didn't
seem to note that both players perhaps
card by the heart hurt and attack
inducing scramble or playing a little
bit more quickly in the beginning of his
game and perhaps trying to save time for
later
exactly exactly very hard inducing okay
so a very different twist because in the
normal expression of cough White has a
knight you know sitting on this rather
passive square a3 in this particular
situation white could go forward early
95 and hopefully trying to get a
position where after a trade of knights
there's not this night on a3 this silly
square another thought that have crossed
my mind is in this position there's an
interesting pawn sacrifice for white I
could consider a move like a four here
b4 Knight here to d5 and in case of
Knight takes e4 I kind of like White's
compensation here there's a lot of light
squares but you're usually getting the
light squares anyway in this defense so
I also mentioned that we have a YouTube
channel where you can watch replays from
the championship including I believe we
will have up the earlier part that some
people miss because of the sound and we
do want to thank spectrum studios and
everyone here who's made all those
recast possible right I'm Esther Maurice
Ashley doing recaps between
the Cardinals games as well as I so it's
pretty exciting on the coverage we've
been getting for this event and they'll
be there all archived me we'll all be
archived and some of them are archived
now honestly it was chess club channel
remember that channel has over seventeen
thousand views I think all maurices
recaps already are up on the channel
what additionally if you want to go back
and relive some of this excitement and
get a little bit more into depth and
some of the variations we're looking to
you will be able to do that as well
and let me just bring up the first the
game in the u.s. championship so let's
start let's just go a little bit slower
from the start queen pawn opening by
Dada Bishop f4 c7 c6 III Bishop f5
normally speaking after we see this move
c7 c6 it's a prelude to an early Queen
b6 trying to take advantage of the fact
that white may have quote prematurely
developed as Bishop on effort for by
attacking the pawn on b2 we did not see
that Bishop f5 Knight of 3 e 6 Bishop e2
has been played and just okay God is
just saying you have a solid position
but so do i so nothing spectacular going
on in this game let me go back to our
ladies championship later in the game
doesn't he right I see a bit of a long
Bishop move there it looks like some
bishops have been traded I really
looking pretty comfortable in this game
I think she's feeling confident after
her victory lies dead remember all she
needs is a draw so we saw it saw this
developing move Bishop d3 castles
castles rook b8 interesting decision
rook b8 Knight jumps to d5 been
expecting that for awhile we see a trade
of knights and Bishop comes out to g5
and we have the current position on the
board the moment I'm looking at the
webcam more moves have been played
Murray's know if you thought there was a
trade on c1 that occurred yeah but a c1
looks like it was clean so what so I'm a
force
you three take c1 and rook takes you
want and rook take c1 and I agree with
you black looks pretty comfortable here
after for example a straightforward move
Bishop e6 intimating that she's prepared
to play Bishop takes d5 further reducing
the pieces off the board just a whole
vacuuming of pieces going on here I'm
pressure managed to wheel out of it
those of you interested in that Nakamura
reference to the ven quarter defense
from games like Botvinnik Fisher and
Roger Bobb Nakamura I you can check out
JM Shearer 77 who has linked to both
games on chess games and he's been one
of our most popular treaters so shout
out to a Jason Shearer and check out
those games on that uh Nakamura Luigi
has mentioned yes so after the move
Bishop e6 I think we've seen a move by
tatianna but I'm not sure what she
played for she did play a four I thought
she I thought I saw this movement to the
Queen side but I wasn't sure if you
played b4 or a four so a four and now
the move rook b8 makes a lot of sense of
the pawn on b5 has already defended
before it even became a weakness so let
us just see what do you think after
Bishop takes d5 he takes d5 let's say
Knight isse Evan not the only move of
course but 97 can white really expect to
have much of an opportunity of winning
this game I wouldn't think so I would
actually think that black is really just
doing very well in arenas choice seems
to have been spot on in this game
so Bishop takes d5 eat XD 597 a trade on
b5 is what I'm expecting and I don't see
how
White's can put any pressure on blacks
position Maurice I'll just ask you the
computer after these trades that I put
on the board how does it evaluate the
situation it definitely thinks black is
perfectly fine black just looks good in
that position I think arena has
equalized and is happy with this
position and somehow thought F is gonna
have to come up with some really strong
moves and the other game just to make
that funky by the way she has to come up
with some creative ideas and the other
game we see dead solid equal position
Chomsky is not gonna take any risk it's
so fascinating throughout this whole
championship how he's handle himself
he has never chosen a risky line he's
decided he's gonna play solid no matter
what he's probably the only player we've
seen in no danger in the championship he
didn't lose any games but you look at
arena crushes path to this title it's
been up and down a rocky she has
definitely had some some heart-stopping
moments just to save herself in this
tournament and then blown a couple of
wins but because of her strong play or
strong enough play she's found herself
in this great situation and
championships on the other hand Chomsky
has been all about solidity no matter
what his path to victory is to just be a
wall to just be a bear and say look if
somebody else wins it congratulations
he even said during one of our
interviews it's time for a new champion
I bet you he's not saying that right now
he's thinking it's time for me to keep
my title number five will be sweet and
he's looking to do that right now and
all he has to do is keep to his style
his style keep to himself if he wins the
game of course he's in if he draws the
game it'll be the same thing no matter
what he says the same thing all the time
I just play the best moves one move at a
time we have a question coming in to USS
James about the production in reference
to Garry Kasparov who Maurice
interviewed just a couple rounds ago and
they asked where is Maurice remember on
you
how garry kasparov said hey Maurice are
you in New York actually Maurice Ashley
is right here in st. Louis with us we've
got this in studio production which was
all set up by spectrum studios with led
by Randy Sinquefield
you might recognize the name right and
Jeanie yeah that's right we actually see
him you know I could be anywhere in the
world that's that's kind of cool though
we could do but nope I'm happy to be
right here in st. Louis it's been a
pleasure being here and working with you
guys for sure the dream team is together
again that's right and Sinquefield cop
it's coming up thinking of that name
right Bishop takes G 3 h2 takes G 3 has
been seen in the game between God and a
Peruvian version has an issue to solve
for the moment what is he going to do
about the pawn on b7 he doesn't he
doesn't want to see Queen takes b7
winning upon landing in the position but
on the other hand can God a potentially
use the open H file at the moment the
answer is a dead no because of the
bishop sitting on f5 but that might be a
factor later if we see a lot of trades
and even you know moves like Knight h4
and stuff like this so for the moment I
don't know how he does it but I prefer
God his position once more like God is
white you like that is black well no I
thought that var had got a cold the
rights that the rights in their
classical game from the tournament I
really thought that var was gonna win
that game it would shock me in fact how
easily God has saved it and didn't seem
at all troubled well I thought he was
gonna go yeah I thought he was gonna get
the night versus Bishop he could have
traded Knights at the particular moment
and when var allowed God to keep a
knight on the board later admitted that
he yeah and gotta felt that way as well
and that's just like an awful ugly ugly
ugly position in my view to defend but
he did it in any case
var is offering got an opportunity to
snap upon off the board Knight d7 was
played oh my
so let us just take a quick look at this
so in the immortal words of my trainer
Nick alignment have gift me the pond are
you thinking it's like you're saying
like some kind of combination between
given gifts yes yeah gift me depart
that's right so gift me the part so
where you would expect straightforward
we're b8 Queen takes now we pause
because you've got to moose well Queen
a5 hangs the night on d7 so you don't
have to moves pardon me rip takes b2
right I mean what else
courage meaning from California
right rook takes be too discouraging
castles for a moment and let's see is
this enough for look I'm not a hundred
percent sure let's say well this move
Knight c3 is bothersome let's say I make
a move I don't know Queen a sex so my
idea is to play a move like Queen a3 as
well as stopping Queen a5 black it still
has to prove this I'm not a hundred
percent sure this is upon sound pawn
sacrifice it's very very familiar
pattern in many lines of the Queens
gambit declined but I'm an old pawn
grabber I like those pawns Maurice am I
wrong 7 is a better move Queen c7
connecting the pieces ok so that you can
prepare to bring your rook into the game
and now the move c5 is possible I think
you'd want to do that yeah as very very
natural move black could bring his
knight around and suddenly he has
something still has some pressure on
this side I'm not sure how you would
play this yes about Knight takes e4
right you could trade nights and then
the other night shows up on e4 and then
just castles yes now this position is
playable although after Knight c3 yeah
well it all looks very straightforward
Maurice rook e1 rook to e1 this work to
e1 rook on f1 to e1 perhaps yeah
and now the move rook takes on e - Wow
okay these tactics suddenly starting to
her in this tricky one Queen to c8 but
that's just a lost ending you're still
you're still in this one though god
that's lost me too and rook takes you
still have your passport
but there's a huge passport for black
yeah so black is still got a lot to
prove that he can save this position
although the bishop is very strong in
this diagonal move f6 is coming with the
King coming over very intriguing line of
play okay and what did he do instead
there's no reason to risk anything here
he traded and just played castles I
think that makes a lot more sense that
pawn sacrifice is just asking for it you
know in a rapid game in a rapid game if
you grab a pawn you must see no almost
no compensation no real conversation
like in the arena crush game you can see
that it was like kind of conversation
but a pawn is a pawn in that isolated
pawn position this one is like wait a
minute why am i donating compensation in
a rapid game and I don't see a clear
untangling of my pieces and giving the
other person chances to to get the game
going so I think calm ski made the
practical decision which is one of the
reasons why he was a world rapid
champion okay I'll take the other side
of that and say he made the wrong
decision because I'm thinking after
Queen b6
black has absolutely nothing to worry
about I think after Queen b6 black has
equalized and dad-dad dead once again
one of the reasons why I'm thinking it's
that they're dead normally but white
would try to play c5 getting a
an expansion on the queenside
but then after just grabbing everything
just take everything off the board take
on v3 take on our three take on f3 play
a move like a five or a six maybe I can
wait for this move before before playing
a six and after a five Black is just
doing great
that wasn't played I see the players are
moving quickly and I'm curious as to
what was played and said rook b8 by var
he didn't play my suggestion of Queen b6
I'll beat him up later
repeat Knight the 92 and Bishop dropped
back I believe to g6 and God is now
still a little bit better after my guy
something important has happened in the
game between eyebrow me on and crush all
right
I brought me on is played to move f4 in
this game and crushes stop to think it
seemed for almost eight minutes maybe
less than that but she is way behind on
the clock she's at 14 minutes and 26
seconds counting down on the tart clock
times I have here the move f4 after you
and I a thought we had seen equality
more or less on the board this move f4
has disturbed her because this is the
kind of move that abiram he likes to
play aggressive opening lines she has to
do it almost anyway she's not like a
calm ski who's going to stay solid but
here she's decided it's time to play m4
and see if I can get something going on
this side of the board conspired the
fact that her majorities on this side
she's looking to try to get something
here because it's not so easy to break
through over here so f4 looking maybe to
play f5 looking maybe to get a pass ball
it takes still fine for black but she
has to defend properly and her time is
starting to take away she better not let
that happen too much I mean she's really
sudden it looks like she's been there
now for at least eight minutes she's
finally played a move Queen b6 check
which we will be responded to instantly
for sure with King h1 and back in your
court that is saying white to black what
are you gonna do I am thinking of
attacking and you know I'm dangerous
that's taught F that's just the way she
is she loves to attack and that's what
she's doing now agreed everything you
say makes perfect sense I don't
understand exactly why
Arina needed that check that was kind of
that's a check that I might I would have
kept in reserve I beg your pardon
I would have played f7 f5 and just said
okay I'm gonna shut off your Bishop on
d3 no Bishop takes h7 check types of
sacrifices no Rovers nothing like that
f5 I'm shutting you down my intention is
to play e5 e for getting a passed pawn
in this position oh no I didn't get my
beautiful blockade set up yes I have
missed it completely Queen takes d6
Bishop c4 discovered check picks up my
queen I didn't get the blockading Queen
on d6 that I wanted and then f5 of
course if you if you move a knight of
five hang well I could set up okay let's
see what she did because I and now the
question is is pawn takes d5 and d6
actually a threat it's not really the
same when you're not waiting upon on on
a5 right right so in that case it
remains to be seen whether the pawn
could just be rounded up in another way
right she could play for example and
move like rook da just these ideas
because obviously in this case the Queen
and the rook defend the d6 square move
we don't have to take on e5 right but on
the other hand if black is able to get
the setup I wanted which was with to
play a five and E for well we Oh sorry
Queen h4 h5 here you just have g6
g6 that looks like a perfectly
reasonable move sure but then maybe I
can play Queen h6 I was thinking you
know well if Queen g5 I guess you're
continuing with f6 right but you could
perhaps play Queen h4 h4 gen and okay we
know we know that you got a play for a
win and maybe you know sacrificing the
pawn and going berserk is what needs to
be done I mean there's some vague
threats of f6 Queen h6 rook f3 you said
Rovers even if you play a consolidating
move good consolidating neither fool I
think you might have four with the idea
that if f6 yeah or let me play Queen
aged six I'll tell you what let me play
Queen h6 just so that you don't have any
Knight h5 issue and ideas to cut me off
you know
so obviously rook takes f4 is on my
agenda d5 to try to keep some lateral
defense going on yes guys we're
surprising one at this moment she's
accepted a slightly worse ending by
capturing on d5 this move she's played
here Knight takes on d5 allowing the
move Bishop h7 check King takes we saw
this Bishop d7 check happened tatata
have in the earlier game against zoton
ski-in Queen takes d5 where white seems
to have a little bit smidgen of pressure
here maybe not much enough to win this
game it looks like arena crusher has
decided I'm just playing for a draw I
don't need to win this game let me just
equalize simply and the position is
almost on the board that we saw she's
taking now on F on f4 and she's just
trying to Hoover everything off the
board and reach our own ending not a bad
strategy all you need is a draw I say
she
we could we could expect rook takes f4
move like Queen c5 queen d3 check the
game goes on slight advantage to have
just because of the pawn structure more
pawn islands in the position for black
then for white closer to a drop as well
we saw f4 by a bohemian now we've seen
before
bye gotta calm ski you he's trying to
get space he does not have any real edge
but he's trying to play for something by
expanding on the Queen side and there's
some action guys on that side of the
board me what we have seen Bishop takes
8 7 King takes 8 7 Queen takes d5 e
takes f4 and does have twice as much
time as I ran it on 10 minutes and
change for arena versus almost 20 and
Counting for Tata counting down of
course we do have a couple comments
coming in from IMS listening into the
show yeah his preference for pawn Rev
certainly has been influenced by a
victor the terrible yes yes absolutely
he would walk through the Gobi Desert
for upon and big influence on me in my
career and a shout out to Viktor
Korchnoi
in his 80s and still trying to get back
at that chessboard he still has a lot of
them and bigger and absolutely and we
also got a comment from John Bartholomew
and I am who's been tweeting with us
for most of the week and he says if I'm
talk to him I'm doing everything it's
possible to force Irina to make a tough
decision
early on so I think he wasn't too fond
of her forcing opening line and then I
mean had clearly already prepared for
the regular tournament game right all
those true yes with a lot of
simplification which makes the odds of
blendering are lower yes but I thought
arena made a really superb opening
choice in hoovering all of these minor
pieces off the board the natural
inclination for thought EF is to get
tactical positions and now she's in just
a major ending where she's trying to
squeeze not her Forte but she does have
an edge hey guys let's not ignore the
other game in the championship section
between a Cobian and calm ski Kamsky now
has a small edge and it's his kind of
position he is he has expanded on this
side of the board with a move before and
now after this trade he can play the
move rook takes d4 preparing to double
lines it's not much it still looks
relatively equal but small edge for calm
ski trying to dominate on those dark
squares a night Cole and on the d6
square he could double rooks this looks
like his kind of position so let's pay
attention to that and add to the fact
that he has 15 minutes and 33 seconds
and version a cobia is down now under 12
minutes so a small ledge for calm ski
again on the clock this is something
that we're gonna have to pay real close
attention to as this game heats up
that's right we do have work takes d4 in
the position and not a calf ski
attempting to put a little pressure on
version of Kobe an even though I think
he's also comfortable with the
possibility that it is an amount
anything he's gonna be a big favorite in
that Armageddon match which he has so
much experience in I think we're more
likely to see an army getting match in
this game than the arena crush our homme
Ian and I guess you could call me a math
teacher I had and of course a draw or
win will finish the Women's Championship
and give her her sixth title Wow yeah
well octave trying to apply a little bit
of pressure in both the clock and the
position honing in on the f7 pawn yeah
and I was just gonna say I really do
like goddess position much more than
maybe the chess engines I like the fact
that White's minority on the Queen side
is doing a fabulous job at restrained
restraining blacks Queen side majority
and I like the fact that white can play
all of these moves so easily naturally
rook F rook c1 to D 196 Bishop f3 put
pressure on b7
and var has fallen into a difficult
position even though the engines may say
nah draw draw draw done so - she's
played some weird moves in her game and
Abraham Yan has found a nice way to get
a little bit of an edge in her game look
at that look at that King that King side
is bit porous right now and with the
three pieces on the open F file it looks
as though Abraham Yan has some chances
right now she can play this move take a
look the move Queen to d3 is possible
very nice move eyeballing this pawn on
d6 eyeballed in the square h7 keeping
this diagonal in check there's some
little bit of pressure here and how do
you deal with the move work to h4 in
this position this could be dangerous
for her it looks as though arena is
gonna be under a little bit of danger if
this move is found going to d3 no way
she's losing this does not get overboard
but it's going to be unpleasant if she
has to deal with this move especially
with the pressure on her clock so it
seems as though one big think right now
is needed by Abraham Yan maybe a two
minutes maybe three minutes you can find
this Noah smooth queen d3 she might put
her opponent under a lot of pressure and
change the complexion of this ladies
championship definitely giving us a
potential Armageddon in both games she
wins this a first we will move to the
final game the Armageddon match exactly
what you saw in the third place match is
to determine who third for a second at
determine who would play in the finals
exactly so I do like this move Queen d3
very much it does all the things you
said you talked about Maurice setting up
for rook h4 and I also just like piling
up against the d6 pawn to Queen d3
excellent move playing for both rook f4
to h4 as well as rook f4 to d4 and going
after the d6 pawn arena's and under a
lot of pressure in what looks like a
very soft position three because what's
the difference with them
order if octave is to play work h4 first
what's the problem players he's got a
package seven cuz g7 is really easily
guarded right cap seven right she's
gonna either hammer on G seven or eight
seven by the way according to the
engines
Brooke cage for is a good move to so a
second move to find here the only thing
is we queen d3 you do gain a natural
idea of also being able to attack the d6
pawn has yes pointed out so that's a
solid tee ruk h4 is just cave woman
chest but clearly she's going out that
rook h4 is like I'm looking at your king
dude or I should say lady doodad looking
at do that right I'm looking after that
king but Queen d3 says I'm looking for
different things at the same time we're
cage for might come where d4 might come
I have you think about quite a few
things so I think Queen D 3 the most
sophisticated move but according to the
engines work h4 is actually just as good
all right well I think I'm gonna go for
a cage for by taco I think she might
play that she isn't a very aggressive
player and that's why it's fun to watch
her in rapid chess because zoton skiing
crush of course have different styles
but I think the styles of opera hominin
crusher even more diametrically opposed
right I mean not that crush hasn't
pulled off of numerous really great
attacks she's also very comfortable with
just a slight edge right more of a
positional player that's right
besides these moves rook H for excellent
Queen d3 excellent I'm thinking about
the move b4 and she played it did she
really
I'm sorry why I'm attracted to the move
b4 is because if whites queen ever lands
on the D Phi square it will be a
dominant dominant lady and also the move
before really says okay your b5 pawn is
going to be a weakness I'm going to
attack on the fifth rank as well
if for example after b4 just for
argument's sake Queen e5 rook can come
to f5 keeping that Queen dancing and now
the weakness of the b5 pawn has made
clear after this moves queen d3 so I'm
not saying that b4 was a great move or
anything like great move but as it from
a tactic from a tactician point of view
it that would attract my eye
Queeny if I played by our eunuch ration
response seven minutes for Irena twice
as much time for talkative
15 minutes she's on the move also I
played the move rook f5 maybe too
quickly because also rookie four
deserves consideration as well
so after rookie for Queen d5 I've got
this nice little move rook d1 and I
could very very quickly switch to pawn
grubber mode and going after that d6
pawn so arena is in trouble against in
my opinion both rook f5 and rookie four
I like White's position suddenly got
better and better thanks to those pawn
islands better and remember the rule
when you have major pieces on the board
the critical thing is king safety King
safety King safety that's usually the
difference
add a little pawn weakness like the one
on d6 the one on b5 that f6 g7 setup and
now it's all the makings of an advantage
for white why it's more coordinated as
well right at this moment she has the
initiative I think that white is for
choice without question in that position
and I also want to take a look at the
game between a Cobian and Kamsky where
white is for choice here - white has
doubled on the D file there is no way to
trade off these pieces on this D line if
you challenge with a rook in d8 and then
capture the Queen can take on this
square so move like rook to the a
commitment by a3 to protect this pawn
and then you could double rooks a double
Queen and rook on this line and that's
gonna be a bit problematic for black by
the way do you remember that moment in
versions game from earlier that he had
against Tomsky when he had white in that
game he also could have played the move
before and he also could have put his
Queen on B - so it's like a mirror of
what could have happened then
Chomsky is doing to him now and maybe
version remembers that game somewhere in
the back of his mind a little bit of a
ghost variation if you will so he's
decided to go for it with the move c5
what is this he is allowed this move in
the position but this looks dangerous
calm Skene operating the move Knight to
d6 cows these pieces look tremendous the
black Queen also could get trapped or or
at least be relegated to weird duty this
is a difficult position for for black
here white has completely taken over the
initiative I think that black is in big
trouble here and I do too and I think
that that was a case of a few moves ago
in fact I think I think that var didn't
appreciate how precipitously his
position had slipped and now he is in
deep trouble because again all very
natural moves by God a domination of the
Open File domination of these Queen side
majeure majority white gets to play a
four bishop f3 all kinds of winning
endings and that majority on the on the
King side by white by the way is making
sure his king is ultra ultra ultra safe
and solid and version big big trouble
and also behind on the clock 12 minutes
to 6 points per game could be big big I
mean not the position per se he's not
it's not like well the position looks
really bad too but the the with a clock
situation it looks over and you know the
thing I'm really worried about is that
knight on f6 and that bishop on g6 they
looked up they look like optically good
pieces but when you stare at them you
say so where are you guys going I mean
right the bishop is on a nice diagonal
yeah but you're hitting nothing black
why species have gravitated to the dark
square so the bishop is just simply
irrelevant the knight on f6 has no
security just pick the knight up and
find a square for it there's nowhere for
it to go that has any long-term security
so it's frozen
meantime white like you said you asked
to put the [ __ ] when f3 as the knight
on d6 the double rooks and the extra
time on the clock and he's the stronger
player it's gonna take a miracle for a
Cobian to get out of this one hour Homs
game against crush she didn't move
rookie 4 and then after Queen g5 she
played this move Queen e2
which targets uh b5 and also perhaps if
murky 7 she can play queen e6 Jack but I
read a now counter-attacking after Queen
d2 so this I don't like Queen e2 one bit
Oh big time strange not just a little
bit big time strange actually
I was thinking that Queen g5 might be
harassed by the move H 2 H 4 I do very
very much appreciate what Marissa said
about King safety but the move H 2 H 4
might have just been able to pursue an
initiative kind of making attack going
on over there I don't like Queen e2 I
would look for something a little bit
more crisper and what has happened some
counter play with rook b c8 just simply
saying okay I'm going after the c3 pawn
and now rookie 7 doesn't seem to really
lead to much except winning the d6 pawn
right because the hide maybe she had
something like rook g4 and Queenie 6
checking ideas in mind although after
Queen d5 that she covers this diagonal
very comfortably with her Queen and this
pawn on c3 is hanging so right now some
regrets for b4 some regrets about the
movie that's slightly guys yes enough
that she's still a little bit better but
it's not quite clear how to impress her
will on this position or impose our will
on this position but importantly while
they're battling we should note this
game only 3 minutes and 30 seconds for
version of Cobian in his game he is so
far behind on the clock now he's having
trouble finding moves he doesn't know
what to do here his only move is
apparently rook to f8 who wants to do
that but he's looking at the idea of
this pawn being taken on b7 which could
be done and there's back rank issues if
his rook ever leaves the back row this
looks busted this
a practical situation looks like a dead
loss game I think that you're gonna see
the US Champion keep his championship
because it's just so overpowering right
now
well he's dominating the position well
Grandmaster Susan Polgar agrees she says
can ski in good shape Bertha Cobian and
crushed should hold Versailles rahani
and perhaps no new champions again no
new champions defending champions win
again you never know in these Rabi games
yeah crazy things again I mean rook f8 I
appreciate that
computer maybe saying that's the only
move it's not the move that a human
player wants to make the human he did
say I mean you know I can understand why
why var was really struggling with that
decision because it's just not a
decision you want to make you know going
passive like that now I recommend them
move a to a four-bit Can I grab this
pawn on b7 Maurice yes just snap the
pond and say okay I'm a pawn up do
something in case of Queen c7 my simple
idea was Bishop f3 just defend the night
and I don't know rooks rooks iguanas
next and or maybe rook before I'm upon
up and I'm happy man it's a point or you
don't have to take it look at the
position it's huge I mean this the Queen
the black queen is a thing I'm actually
just eyeballing my position when I look
at this which I'm thinking can I trap
that Queen somehow clearly that's kind
of way out there in fantasy land but
with the way the white pieces are so
dominant right now I wouldn't doubt if
white just kept playing moves I'm over
like Bishop f3 instead of grabbing the
pawn look at the white pieces it's crazy
there's gonna be tricks and how do you
save yourself when you only have a
couple of minutes and their potential
tricks everywhere in the game I mean
that's gonna be the hardest thing
there's just you're just gonna blunder I
mean you cannot give Kamsky this much
time odds and expect to save the game
when you're actually worse as well I'll
have bad position and for compensation
I'll have bad time too that doesn't work
well John Gustafson actually mentioned a
really cute tactic
if instead of the computer issue brick a
fade version of Cobian played the more
natural work eighty-eight actually Queen
takes b7 is a potential move here with
the idea that after work takes b79 takes
b7 there's no real time to play work
takes d4 because I've Knight takes e5
just winning and game right and we're
probably in probably a six looks like
it's gonna hang as well in that line
meanwhile ugly stuff on the back rank
many many pushups the pawn by the way
that's a pretty wanna know is it's under
massive pressure and instead Knight
takes b7 in this position Queen a seven
on the board right over ten forgot
account Gary defending champion because
it wasn't just Knight takes b7 but
Bishop takes a6 was God as planned as
well so that's why we saw the Queen
dropping back to a7 Maurice talking
about getting your Queen into a bad spot
well the Queen on a7 just makes a very
poor quite quickly
yeah but okay rook before definitely
breaks the pennant on the spot and
prepares our knight to retreat either to
a5 or d6 that's just a very good pun no
is the fact that the extra pawn is the e
pawn or maybe you might say it's the GG
pawn right that's the only hope and
dream in which that a Cobian has here
that maybe it's not so easy to make this
extra majority working on the other side
of the board and if you could somehow
calm down the pressure on his pawn on a6
then maybe he'll just might make it out
of here alive into some draws ending but
that's far away in the position and take
a look at this game it looks as though
Tata has made some strange moves and has
given the champion a big chance back in
the game who could have dreamt that she
would coordinator rook so easily against
the one weakness in the position or
queen as well place now this
absolutely nothing wrong with blacks
position white has thrown away the
advantage that she had in on the board
she could only hope now that with only
three and a half minutes left in the
game that that crush will not be able to
handle herself properly but white has to
be sitting there thinking what did I do
I had something within those last couple
of moves and I've thrown it away now and
there's nothing to really play for
that's so powerful that pawn on c3 is
definitely hanging and it looks as
though arena is back in business
absolutely h3 okay so rook h3 setting up
for a check but is that just does that
lead anywhere specifically after it
takes c3 right and you just think that
the they're working games with that with
a pretty safe King four black is gonna
be just really black hitting on before
and nothing for why it so instead we got
to try Queen eight seven but just this
is a seven leading to nothing well the
problem is is that you don't even get
the move rook g3 I've black rook on c3
stops any kind of attack this just looks
dreadful in fact for what maybe yeah
Albert humming on just trying to keep
ahead in the clock but that's over doing
that and then I'm just not getting
enough right because as much time as I
know now it's quite ticking down right I
think she'll sue she'll come back to
this position before she made the move
before and regret the fact that she
didn't play your move Jen look h4 or
queen d3 because there's something here
for white there there's no question
arena was in trouble here but when these
moves were kicked around arena's Queens
actually landed on a really good square
Queen g5 gotta be the culprit right and
this is an Queen this move Queen d3
doesn't look that good to me either
maybe it was time to make lifts and
after h3 just to be able to play rook f3
and to keep the pawn
see three because now after Queen D
three this move is too easy to find this
is this that this is a layup for arena
arena sitting with rook c8 I'm just
gonna hit for the pawn on c3 and I'll
play Queen versus two rooks happily not
going to lose that with black so after
Queen d3 Tatia think sitting there
thinking well how can I make it
difficult for my opponent what can I do
rooks have been traded the unpin has
happened unpinning of the night and it
just looks as though I version is trying
to bring his bishop into the game but
White's pieces are perfect and now he's
headed toward the the black King now I
mean take a look at this that's right
pull this up I mean an I donate five
this night was on b7 a second ago now
it's on the f5 this Queen was sitting
over here on b2 now it's on f4 thinking
about Queen g5 what happened
defend against Knight hd7 it does not
Queen takes a crushing blow this we are
about to have a new us well not a new US
Champion we're about to have a three
time repeating champions we talked about
for got a Kamsky after and kind of
unimpressive for him result in the
regular time in draw and then different
result and a bit lenok when push comes
to shove he's the man to me you can't
vote against got a Kempsey in Rapids you
know I believe we had the position of
the King g8 two pawns up dominating
position simply rook d4 and that's it
close so the title again to be destroyed
like this it's going to be dejected to
him he was leading the tournament at one
point he's playing so beautifully and
then he tripped at the end losing Valley
to Shanklin than drawing a game that he
should have beaten calm ski when he had
the chance
whether I'm beatin but had an edge and
then the game against the Linderman he
couldn't do anything and now after
playing brilliantly in the time pressure
in the rapid game now just falling apart
against gotta come see not able to break
through and got a nose this is over yeah
he's ready to claim his title you know
even though a lot of people weren't
impressed by God I in the regular time
control there were a couple highlights
those games against for Dalaman Durman
special airs were really doing great in
the tournament gotta show his classic
style combining attack strategy and
quiet moves things like f3 against
Slenderman the rerouting of the night
and attack oh no no when when when it's
time to perform I mean that's what he's
about I mean he wins the big games big
and that's why he's our defending
champion and that's why he's going for a
three-peat Maurice earlier remember I
said that he had no troublesome games
the one game that he had trouble in was
the one against the cobia yeah that was
the one game where he might have been
pushed over and again we saw him play
similar maneuvers putting his pawn on b4
Queen OB to the same way a Cobian should
have and look at a cobia now head in
hands he's just shedding pawns pawns are
dropping from the board like a5 Bishop
takes h7 by the way three pawn advantage
for gotta this is over and let's go to
our ladies because I had a pawn in this
position okay let's just go back when we
left it we saw the position with Queen
d3 rook g3 was played by thethe rook g4
Queen takes d6 takes check oh this looks
like a Kobe and if that's resigned by
the way just on the board a move worked
eh act winning and he Peruvian lost this
game actually you want to bring up that
final position in a little traffic roar
gata Kamsky or
u.s. champion yet again three so we are
gonna toss Takada after this game is
over so let's move right back to the
Women's Championship if she thought that
can win this game and create an are
beginning oh my goodness
so arena missed us nice little tactic
here I think she got to this position in
her mind's eye and was only seeing the
move Queen takes g3 and anticipating
that she would make a comfortable draw
as black but this move Queen a six check
rocked her because after Queen takes her
intended rook takes g2 would have lost
on the spot to queen h3 check picking up
the rook that didn't happen
obviously and after Queen takes she had
to move her rook rook e3 and that's how
White has ended up upon up is it enough
h2 h3 making love gone back she has won
oh she's she is no longer down no it's
queen f5 because what happened is what
happened yes Queen g4 queen g4 could
take c3 and now Queen F I check King GA
o cannot touch the beep on does not work
because that's an instant draw a
perpetual check Women's Champion so
that's the all she needs is a draw so
let's go back why did why did TF could
have played Queen f5 check and gone into
the rook ending up that's a draw that's
okay
never mind so what has happened we see
three realizing of course that she can't
take on d5 and hand championship and
she's just gonna have to play some other
move but five check Queenie try check
and maybe move and okay the King moved
to g8 and then she checked her again
wellhe five and now the king is a back
on h7 she's gonna have to try him he may
be a rover and she tried the check again
she played check on on f5 and after
dropped her queen back to have to dr.
queen back to F - okay well that's a
good point on the right direction
yeah ultra solid by the way rook the e5
pawn on b4 is less than two minutes but
again you can create now know she's
cruising to a drawn position and she
looks to be keeping her title as well so
this been about three e's hasn't it
yeah the three-way playoffs now we have
a three-peat for gata Kamsky just pretty
incredible how this tournament is
progressing and then it's also going to
be a three-peat for Irina and rook d1 a
pawn sacrifice rope d1 is going down
upon this speculative move is a lot of
Queen takes before blacks just up a pawn
now that's just a straight pawn mm-hmm
she's just I mean it's better this than
giving you a perpetual that's such as
logic but not know she says in the game
for there to be cheapos really exactly I
don't see the CP the cheapo potential
rook da check King h7 instantly played
by the way I thought that deserved a
thought but no off the board after
rookie for Queen e1 check rookie once a
king h2 in this what happened is king h7
pardon me
after King h7 worked the 4-byte octave
but Queen e1 check leaning you wan work
takes you on and this is over it's a
draw and that we won't have you won't
have a we're gonna have to three-peat
u.s. champions in both the Women's
Championship three in a row fry and a
crash and in the champion three in a row
for gotta camp skate
absolutely tell me what has happened
after King h2 King Asia we have rookie 5
TG 3 King g6 King f4 rook c5
oh sorry look at the way our army on is
losing please check
she is just moving limply and look
they've repeated moves and agreed on a
draw arena chant and right now crush is
once again the champion somewhat
anticlimactic in a way because they
dominated those games that's right I
mean the two favorites have emerged
victorious and we've got arena crush
again in the Women's Championship gata
Kamsky again in the US Chess
Championship wait wait playoffs two
three times in a row champions and this
is the sixth title for Irina crash Wow a
thrilling playoff what and end to an
exhausting two weeks by the way I mean
it was a lot of work but boy that was
fun to watch and as we get our newly
crowned US Champion set up thoughts
missed offered so many missed
opportunities I'm sure Alex Lenderman
will go back thinking what it could have
been just one little move here or there
a Cobian VAR a great great tournament
for him he had it within his grasp
after going 4-0 on a really nice run ran
into Sam Franklin that's really nice
game and here he is the US Champion
three times in a row
we've got gata Kamsky dominating in the
rapid portion of this event Ryan I mean
yes just clear very comfortable game
with black even on the plus side of that
always on the clock I don't think he was
behind on the clock at any moment right
now just very solid and here he is he's
with Maurice Ashley with the new new
this year's u.s. champ not the new but
the old is once again new US Champion
gata Kamsky first of all got to
congratulations on defending your title
thank you
you know I have five US Championship
titles how does that feel when you when
you go back and look at your career well
it's still the career to go
what does five sound like to you it's
gonna look good on the resume
okay no one feels great of course but I
didn't expect to win this year because I
mean you guys saw how I play I was
behind all the time behind the leaders
sometimes even one point behind so I
didn't think it was really possible but
then and yesterday against Kobe and he
missed a win against Thunderman and it
was basically one or two moves and he
had the superior position and again mmm
the nurse probably they played their
role and we got to the playoffs and in
playoffs anything can happen
indeed you have been here before you
played rapid you've been world rapid
champion in fact you feel that that was
really important in this playoffs well I
feel that that certainly gave me an
extra edge because I have this huge
experience playing Rapids and it feels
comfortable to play here so and of
course I can see that you know when both
landsman and a Kobe on they were really
nervous thank their rapid games and that
tells you that you know when you're when
you're comfortable when you have all
experience playing the games then you
know what to do so that helped is it is
it just experience you think or do you
have a strategy when you're playing
rapids it's about moving quickly or
playing your type of positions it is
both you know exactly what works for you
because you played there or you maybe
already made all the mistakes that you
could have made and so now you know what
to do just play solid try not to blunder
anything and stay ahead on time that's
the main ingredients of course and of
course the thing is you know to get a
comfortable position sure because so you
know what to do so you know you have
some moves that's important did you
think at all about a moment in the game
when you had a pawn on b4 and a queen on
b2 that he had that on you in your
matchup individual matchup in the
championships and maybe psychologically
he feel pressure at that moment no but
those kind of structures are always nice
to play with white because I played them
with black all the time and I knew that
that this very important position to be
faced with so I understand why he plays
c5 which I considered a proper losing
move because after that I just get that
funky sound immediately and and then
just yeah just stayed and played and
defended probe
we'll have been a draw but it's
unpleasant ask you corrected us and said
that you're the two-time back-to-back
champion the nine more one three years
ago right what's next for you you've won
this title we've heard some rumors of
retirement you still seem to be oh
you're definitely one of the top players
in the world top fifty years so 2,700
what's your plans are for the near and
distant future well right now I'm going
to celebrate this with my fiancee she is
here she's been supporting me in the
cold tournaments and she's been standing
like wishing my games in the playoffs so
I'm very grateful to for her presence of
course and then we're just gonna
celebrate this victory and then probably
play a national open in Las Vegas later
this year and then I have no idea I'm
just gonna see what happens no idea
you've won the title it's five times
your name is etched in the history of
these championships got a
congratulations on the deserving
championship thank you
Grandmaster gotta calm ski the five-time
US champion this year is 2014 champion
once again a showing that he is a force
to be contended with at this tournament
guys so God it was wrong he said it's
fine for News and our congratulations of
course to gada for a very impressive
victory playing well when it really
counted and he did he just played very
good chess when all the marbles were at
stake you just can't argue with rapid
kills I think that clearly his
difference in Rabbid skills just a
massive massive gauge and a really tough
task for both Lenderman Akopian I think
Ramirez got closer last year well sure
it was that's the point
I I'm not sure I really like okay the
playoffs were known in advance I mean we
everybody had a contract they knew the
rules
nobody really perceived it is a big edge
if you have to play a preliminary
Armageddon and you're nervous and you've
just wasted a lot of nervous energy
getting through to the final yeah
yeah also was made more tough because
coincidentally we're not completely
coincidentally but it hasn't happened
the people who were also the best
players yeah it's true so I appreciate
all the innovations and all the ideas
that have been tried here at the st.
Louis chess club and have us change I
would call I I'd call for a rethink on a
play off of three play players just I
call for a rethink of what happened this
year it's too big an edge I'm getting
set up for an interview with Maurice
actually so she will talk about that
struggle against Irena crash well the
first game especially obviously the
pressure is really on right in the
second game it's true on the other hand
you know I really thought that when
Arena won against Anna sitarski that she
had deserved the title so to speak
because she had beat her main rivals but
well just the way the format she needed
to play very well that again today
against Taunton and here she is and her
active are behind me and a fantastic
result here
she's with Maurice Ashley well purple is
the color of the day and well talked to
have today was a tough day I mean you
had to play against honours atone ski a
four-time champion and then have to
defeat a five-time champion how
difficult is that nine championships
that you have to hurdle over to win your
first title impossible well the first
game on you played very aggressively
which usually doesn't do and I think I
got a really bad position but she must
have misplayed something so things went
my way and against iron in the first
grey first game I played all really
aggressive I'm not sure why maybe
because after Megan from Susanna was so
intense or so crazy so I just started
playing too aggressive and at some point
I just kind of thought to myself why am
I being so aggressive I'm playing black
if I try it's fires
but I mean I think I was flying just
kind of floundered at the end all the
palms the this format of Yasser was
saying is really hard on the person who
has to play that first game did you feel
fatigue or nerves creeping after that
first game to have to play two games
right after that well I mean of course
it's tougher to play more games but what
did it affect you did you feel it affect
you or did you feel like you were you
know being able to play a fresh game in
the in the next two games were you able
to put that first game on your mind and
just play chess I mean it's just more
even if you don't feel it or if you
think you don't feel it I think is still
tiring to have to play an extra game and
that game was different time control
you're playing different time so it's
really hard to adjust indeed you have
come close before we had a joke early
that this was a two and a half horse
race you've proven to be more than just
half a horse horse what does it take to
to beat these ladies I mean you're
you're that you've come this close now
at least twice I think I was just kind
of taken aback because it's really waken
and we can ignore and she just kept
holding our position and I just wasn't
able to create anything and she spent so
much time too so I thought you know like
things weren't really going my way I'd
like my position I had a lot of time and
then I just wasn't able to create
anything indeed you did have an edge on
the clock and your position to us looks
really good as well what's it what's the
difference what makes Arenacross who she
is I mean I know you don't necessarily
want to study her too much but you have
studied her more than most people have
what's the difference in her play that
puts her at the level she's on on her
planned in her play just in general why
she wins all these chances are six
championship what's the reason for that
well I mean she's a good player but I
mean I mean if you take the US
championship field especially in the
previous years I mean it was just her an
onion they were so ahead of the field so
I don't think it's that surprising to
see her and on I just keep winning it
interchangeably basically but well I
mean she's been studying for so long and
playing along of course she's a lot of
I think all that comes into play of
course is a good clothes 2500 she's a
gem indeed you're finished now with this
championship do you have any plans for
the future have you thought about what's
next for you just once yes well I think
I'll play in Las Vegas and I was
thinking maybe some other tournament but
I think I'll do some event political
afford Olympian strolling period so
Olympia it's gonna be my main next main
tournament so you'll be representing the
US team the u.s. women's team we
certainly wish you best of luck there
and congratulations on a fine finish we
know you almost came close but we have
confidence you'll get in the future
years thank you
Tata Barbara mignon after another tough
battle fighting for the championship
she's very close but certainly acquitted
herself well here at the ladies
championships guys it was a great ladies
Championships I enjoyed the battles very
much and I thought that following the
games day after day after day it often
times felt to me like we saw more
excitement in the ladies it was great to
have alongside right this year I
actually think the championship really
rivaled it in terms of the decisive
games were just outstanding yeah and
what was interesting about the women's
championship was this massive drama in
the last round with mem Cova and me
fighting so admirably and their
opponents almost it's roaming our
defending champion absolutely and them
cover as well in the end is resulting in
draws and wild unbelievable situation
and here she is
Irina crash now a six-time US Women's
chess champion she's with Murray
Saturday indeed with grandmaster arena
crush arena congratulations on your
victory thank you Morris
how does it feel six times that's a big
number it's a big number you know um
often in the last in the last year when
people were introducing me they would
say by mistake and a sixth time you
women's dancing I would correct them but
I thought maybe maybe they're not making
this mistake by accident so but of
course during the course of this
my victory seemed very far so I think
this is it feels like you know I really
pulled victory out of you know well
what's with because yeah so I think from
that point of view this was the hardest
championship I've ever played because
the other ones I've won either well I
was never coming from behind you know
maybe like half a point was the maximum
which at some point I might have been
trailing Anna but here you know in the
middle of the tournaments obviously just
got away from me
you know I mean I made so many draws in
this tournament I did not convert
several winning positions so it's my
worst result here since 2009 you know my
worst result ever I think except like
2009 so you still managed to pull it off
yeah after all that what did what did it
take to to pull it off you think this
time around well I guess the first thing
I think I mentioned it to you is that
when I play these big events and I know
how much people root for me the first
things that I'm not I don't play like
for myself you know or for my own glory
first thing is that you know when I see
how much like my coach puts into
preparing me and you know doesn't sleep
nice you know while he's preparing me in
Alex you know obviously I feel a big
sense of responsibility towards him your
coach George George is really Grand
Master they're gonna get his name right
there you go I got it right one time
yeah so that's um that's something
that's very important to me to do well
for the people who have invested their
time and efforts into me and I think you
know the hardest thing for me in this
tournament was at some point I really
just didn't feel any faith or confidence
that I could win yeah I mean like like
that middle of the tournaments when I
one point behind Anna and as I mentioned
before and I wasn't feeling that well
didn't feel a lot of energy and I just
thought well why would this be the
tournament I win I mean I'm gonna point
behind I'm not playing that well you
know what am I gonna do to change this
course of events and it was very hard
for me to really feel confident and you
know one of my favorite passages in the
in the gospel it's um it's when a man
who was talking to Jesus you know he
said help my unbelief
you know um so he said I believe help my
unbelief
like simultaneously you know and that's
basically that was my whole the kind of
thoughts that I had in my mind through
this whole tournament just - I always
asked for help to have the faith that I
could do it indeed even after five
championships you manage to defeat
owners of Tomsky in your head-to-head
battle I mean doubt that was a
tremendous fight that went down to the
wire as well did you feel after you
defeated her that this was this was now
the [ __ ] back on course and that you had
the title back in your hands you know
you said the ship back on course at
first I thought well yes I did think
that after the game with an I mean I
started to feel better physically
obviously gave me a big energy boost
that victory you know just a
psychological boost you know my coach
actually arrived that day into st. Louis
Saturday night so that was some extra
energy for me and um but you know I had
so many setbacks in this tournament just
really was like setback after setback I
mean even in the last round my winning
position I managed to have to defend you
know turn a winning position into one
where actually was close to losing
although to be honest I was playing for
the win until almost the very end so I
think maybe that helped me a little bit
you know my opponent would probably feel
that maybe uh maybe she wasn't that
confident that she was so much better
because I was still trying to win but
yeah and yesterday I was just so
deflated that was just my overall
feeling
winning position didn't make anything of
it that so yesterday I felt deflated
I was probably very bad company at
dinner just kind of staring into my cell
phone when I went out with Georgie and
Alex but but you know somehow you know
chess teaches you to be to be a fighter
and I've been in this teach these
situations a lot before and somehow when
your back is pressed against the wall
you know you've got to show what you're
made of
so no I you know I thank God that you
know he gave me the capacity to suffer
because suffering makes you stronger so
well there you go well you certainly
have proven yourself here six
championships is nothing to sneeze at
and will go down in the annals of these
tournaments you'll go down as a great
champion congratulations on your victory
thank you can I say congratulations also
it's a gotta our us champion and I am
very happy for Brooklyn today Brooklyn's
in the house that's what's up
our six-time champion that's a huge
number Grandmaster arena crush a
deserving victory on her part she is at
the top of the US should I just say one
last thing Margot I just forgot to say
actually the tats have played very well
you know we had a very hard-fought match
you know I mean it was very close in
both games
indeed giving credit to her as well
she'll be coming back again for sure and
you guys will be playing on the Olympic
team together quite soon so once again
friends rooting for each other
but the battle goes to the champion once
again arena crush is the ladies champion
for 2014 guys chess teaches you a lot it
just teaches you to persevere to fight
to the end and to suffer quite a message
our new and reigning 2014 US Women's
Champion it has an Jennifer let me get
that in as well
it's been a pleasure to be with you and
Maurice working with masters Maurice
Ashley and yassir's heroin these last
couple weeks and a
again with batching studios yes just
been so much fun
yes final work for Maurice Ashley indeed
Jen this was a pleasure working with you
guys again it was so much fun
feels feels like the dream team like I
said the chemistry is wonderful the
championships were awesome this year
more than ever
I watched quite a few of these
championships but this one went right
down to the wire the champions showed
their mettle it's what it's all about
just fighting chess it may not have been
the most perfect chess the most pristine
chess but you don't need that you need
fighting fun chess chess that keeps the
audience's entertain on the edges of
their seat and we saw that time and time
again here in these championships so I'm
really grateful to be a part of this
event what a great job they do here at
the Chess Club of course the the sound
guys the the TV crew everybody fetch him
everyone here it's just such a classy
place if you have not been to st. Louis
you're missing something on the chest
scene you've got to visit one of these
days and I'm glad I get to visit quite a
bit so thanks so much guys
and see you next year see you at the
Sinquefield Cup that's right the
Sinquefield cop named after the founders
here I was just focusing Jeanne
Sinquefield we absolutely can't wait for
that and that's coming up really soon
right yes in August so book your plane
tickets and again congratulations to our
winner of the US chess championship got
a camps neat you could've hit $45,000
you
really one when it counted
and I read across taking home $20,000
for repeat performance here at the ludus
Chess Champion thank you all all over
the world for joining us we expect you
back for a couple months
don't forget there's also big Junior
Championships you want to watch that
here as well the Senior Cup starting on
August 26 when you picked everyone for
listening to us yah so do you have any
final words thank you to the audience of
course as well and also do keep in mind
that the st. Louis Chess Club itself is
an educational entity foundation all
contributions all donations
tax-deductible and we just hope they you
will support the club and make it your
favorite charity as it is mine that's
right the world chess Hall of Fame join
both of the organizations start with
that come over and check out what's
going on and these wonderful
institutions thanks for joining us guys
it's been amazing see you in a couple of
months for it missing field cup and more
action
[Music]
[Music]